in the last video we work through an
example of using a computation graph to
compute a function J now let's take a
cleaned up version at their computation
graph and show how you can use it to
figure out derivative calculations for
that function J so here's a computation
graph let's say you want to compute the
derivative of J with respect to B so
what is that well this says if we were
to take this value of B and change it a
little bit how would the value of J
change well J is defined as um V times D
and right now B is equal to 11 so then
with the bump up B by a little bit to 11
point oo 1 then J which is 3 B so
currently 33 will get bumped up to
thirty three point zero three so here
we've increased V by 0.001 and the
result of that is that J goes up three
times as much so the derivative of J of
respect to B is equal to three because
the increase in J is three times the
increase in V and in fact this is very
analogous to the example we have in the
previous video where we had on F of a
equals three a and so we then derive
that DF da which was slightly simplified
study sloppy notation you can write as
DF da was equal to three right so
instead here we have J equals BB and so
DJ DB is equal to three with here J
playing the role of F and V playing the
role of a in this previous example that
we had right from from an earlier video
so indeed terminology of back
propagation what we're seeing is that if
you want to compute the derivative of
this final output variable which usually
is a variable your camels about what
expect to be then we're done you know
sort of one step of back propagation so
we've got one step backwards in this
graph now let's look at another example
what is DJ da in other words if we bump
up the value of a how does that affect
the value of J well let's go through the
example right now a is equal to five so
let's bump it up to five point zero one
the net impact of that is at D which was
a plus u so that was previous eleven
this we can increase the eleven point
over one and then we've already seen as
above that J now gets run pups to thirty
three point zero zero three so what
we've seen is that if you increase a by
0.001 J increases by 0.03 and by entry
is a I mean if you were to take this
value five and just plug in a new value
right then the change to a will
propagate to the rights of the
computation graph so the J ends up being
thirty three point zero three and so the
increase the J is three times the
increase to a so that means this
derivative is equal to three and one way
to break this down is to say that if you
have if you change a then that would
change B and through changing B that
would change a and so the net change to
the value of J when you bump up the
value and when you nudge the value of a
up a little bit is that um first by
changing a you end up increasing B well
how much does do entries right it is
increased by an amount determined by DVD
a and then the change in V will cause
the value of J to also increase so
calculus is actually called the chain
rule that is a affects V of X J then the
amount that J changes when you nudge a
is the product of how much B changes
when you nudge a times how much J
changes when you nudge B so in calculus
um again this is called the chain rule
and what we saw from this calculation is
that if you increase a by point zero one
D changes by the same amount so DV da is
equal to one so in fact if you plug in
what we have worked our previously on
DVD J is equal to three and DVD a is
equal to 1 so the product of these three
times one then I should say to the
correct value that DJ da is equal to 3
so this illustration shows how by having
computed DJ DV as its derivative respect
to this variable it can then help you to
compute DJ da and so that's another step
of this um backward calculation I'm just
going to use one more new notational
convention which is that in when you're
writing code to implement
back-propagation they'll usually be some
final output variable that you really
care about all right so the final output
variable that you really care about
whether you want to optimize and in this
case this final output variable is J is
really the last node in your computation
graph and so a lot of the computations
will be trying to compute the derivative
of that you know final output variable
so D of this final output variable with
respect to some other variable and just
call that the VAW right so a lot of the
computations you have will be to compute
the derivative of the final output
variable really J in this case we'll
various intermediate variables such as
ABC
your V and when you implement this in
software you know what do you call this
variable name alright one thing to do is
in Tison you can write you know gives us
a very long variable name ID final
output of all over a DVR but that's a
very long variable name you could call
this a guess DJ v bar but because you're
always taking derivatives respect to DJ
respect to this final output variable
I'm going to introduce a new notation
we're in code when you are computing
this thing in the code you write we're
just going to use the variable name d
VAR in order to represent that quantity
okay so d PA are in the code you write
will represent the derivative of the
final output variables you care about
such as J or sometimes the loss L will
respect to the various intermediate
quantities of computing in your code so
this thing here in your code you know
you use them DV to denote this value so
DV would be equal to 3 and your code you
represent this as a DA right which is
how we also figured out to be equal to 3
okay so um with some back propagation
partially through this computation graph
let's go through the rest of this
example on the next slide so let's go to
a cleaned up copy of the computation
graph and just to recap what we've done
so far is go backward here and figured
out that DV is equal to 3 and again the
definition of DV that's just the
variable name of the code is really DJ
DV I will figure out that D a is equal
to 3 and again da is the variable name
in your code and that's really the value
of DG da and what sort of hand-wave how
you never gone backwards on these two
edges like so now let's keep computing
derivatives or let's look at the value
you so what is DJ
you well through a similar calculation
is what we did before and we start off
with you equals six if you bump up you
to six point zero one then B which is
previous eleven goes up to eleven point
over one and so J goes from 33 - 33
point of or three and so the increase in
J is 3 X so this is equal and the
analysis but U is very similar to the
analysis we did for a this is actually
computed as um DJ D V times DV e you
where this we have already figured out
was three and this turns out to be equal
to one so we've kind of one more step
background collation we end up computing
that vu is also equal to three and D U
is of course just this d JD u now we'll
just step through one last example in
detail so what is DJ D P right so you're
imagine if you are allowed to change the
value of B and you want to treat be a
little bit in order to minimize or
maximize the value of K right so what is
the derivative what's the slope of this
function J when you change the value of
B a little bit it turns out that using
the chain rule for calculus this can be
written as the product of two things is
d GJ be u times V u DB and the reasoning
is if you change be a little bit so B
goes from 3 to say the point 0 1 um the
way of no effect J is it will first
affect you so how much does it affect
you well U is defined as B times C right
so this will go from 6 when B is equal
to 3/2 now our 6.00 to right because C
is equal to 2
in our example here and so this tells us
that D u DB is equal to 2 because when
you bump up B by PI no 1 u increases
twice as much so d UD be this is equal
to 2 and now we know that U has gone up
twice as much as B has gone up well once
DJ vu we've already figured out that
this is equal to 3 and so by multiplying
these two out we find that DJ DB is
equal to 6 and again here's the
reasoning for the second part of the
argument which is we want to know when
you goes up by point 0 2 how does that
affect J the fact that DJ D u is equal
to 3 that tells us that when you goes up
by point 0 2 J goes up 3 times as much
so J should go up by 0.06 right so so
bill that comes from in fact that each
ad U is equal to 3 and if you check the
map in detail you will find that if B
becomes 3 point 0 1 then you become six
point zero 2 V becomes 11.0 - alright so
that's a plus u so this 5 Plus u and
then J which is equal to 3 times B then
ends up being equal to 33 point zero
zero six right and so that's how you get
that
DJ DB is equal to 6 and to fill that in
this is if we go backwards so this is DB
is equal to 6 and DB really is the
Python code variable name for you know
DJ DB and I won't I won't go through the
last example in great detail but it
turns out that if you also compute our
DJ this turns out to be DJ D u times D
you and this turns out to be nine it
turns out these three times three I
won't go through that example in detail
Pucelle through this last step it is
possible to derive that B C is equal to
so the key takeaway from this video from
this example is that when computing
derivatives in computing all of these
derivatives the most efficient way to do
so is through a right-to-left
computation following the direction of
the red arrows and in particular we'll
first compute the derivative respect to
B and then that becomes useful for
computing the derivative with respect to
a and the derivative with respect to U
and then the derivative with respect to
U for example this term over here in
this term over here those in turn become
useful for computing the derivative
spected be in the director of respect to
C so that was the computation drop and
how there's a forward or left to right
calculation to compute the cost function
such as JD you might want to optimize
and a backwards or a right-to-left
calculation to compute derivatives if
you're not familiar with calculus or the
chain rule I know some of those details
when they gone by really quickly but you
didn't follow all the details don't
worry about it in the next video we'll
go for this again in the context of
logistic regression and show you exactly
what you need to do in order to
implement the computations you need to
compute the derivatives of the logistic
regression model